hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor before we get started i want
to tell you about something new that i'm
doing and that is providing you with
free board notes so for my most recent
videos including this one i am taking a
picture of the finished board so once
all the notes are on it and all the
blanks are filled in i'm going to grab a
picture of it put it in pdf format
and put it um in a google drive folder
where you can access it for free so if
you're interested in finding those board
notes check out the link in the
description
also remember to subscribe my channel
has a 150 videos biology study videos
and i'm putting up more videos to help
you learn biology um every every week so
please check that out and make sure you
subscribe now let's get started with
today's topic and that is population
bottlenecks so first let's talk about
what a bottleneck is a population
bottleneck it is a very sharp reduction
in the size of a population
so sharp reduction in the size of a
population
and this is due to either some kind of
environmental calamity or to some kind
of human activity that really decimates
the size of a population
it's important that you realize that
this happens over a very short
time frame
i'm gonna put that in all caps with an
exclamation point
so it's a very short period of time
we're not talking about population
declines due to climate change over the
course of decades right we're talking
about there being a sudden environmental
calamity like a drought like a flood
like a famine like a disease that can
wipe out a majority of a population say
80 percent of the population 90 of the
population in a very short amount of
time um in a few
days and a few weeks and a few months
so these right here would be
examples
of some of these environmental
calamities
um
it's also possible for human activities
to do this so we have some examples
written here i think um
you know over hunting um there's
certainly evidence that in just a few
short years
uh passenger pigeons were like wiped off
the face of the planet that's not even a
bottleneck right that's an extinction
because of over hunting
intentional culling
where 90 of a population is killed in a
short amount of time would also fall
into this uh this example
habitat destruction think about some
species that are maybe only present in a
few forests and then those forests are
deforested you know 90 of that habitat
is just gone in a few short years
something else humans might do is
introduce non-native
competitors
or predators so if you suddenly have
like a new predator
in a region that has never been before
or a new competitor for like a limiting
resource is certainly introduced by
humans that can have major decimating
effects over a short time period
on native populations
so all of these right here
would be examples of human activities
that could lead to a population
bottleneck
now before we go on to why this matters
so much i do want to tell you where we
get this name bottleneck think of the
net of a bottle right imagine that i've
got like a two liter bottle and it's
laying on its side and there's the neck
right and then there's the opening of
the bottle
so what we're seeing with population
bottlenecks is that the size of the
bottle
represents
the population
size and this right here represents time
and there is remember over a short
period of time just a sudden decrease in
population size where instead of having
a population size like this you go to
population size like this that's why
it's called a population bottleneck
imagine a population being cut down
until it can sort of fit through the
bottleneck in much smaller numbers
so that's our population bottlenecks now
let's talk about why
it matters this is what your your
professor most cares about you knowing
bottlenecks reduce genetic variation in
a population
and this is a big deal
in a healthy
thriving population you expect to see a
lot of genetic variation okay a lot of
diversity
that means that populations have a great
number of different alleles remember
allele as an alternative form of a gene
that helps them to
be able to handle when hardships come
their way
so when you have this great reduction in
genetic variation in a population first
it makes the population less robust
and what do we mean by that just like
more
susceptible um there will be less
genetic variation and so if like the
environment suddenly changes or humans
suddenly start doing some of this you've
got a population that is already smaller
but also genetically weaker there's just
less
diversity in the types of genes
and then the population can struggle to
adapt so making them less able to adapt
to any future calamities that happen
in very severe bottlenecks
entire alleles
can be
lost just gone from the population
remember what is an allele
an allele is an alternative
form
of a gene
the best way to think about this is that
when you have sexually reproducing
species they're going to get half of
their genetic material from the mother
and half of their genetic material from
the father and so even though they're
inheriting like the same genes like a
gene from
um from each parent for eye color for
example
they can get different versions
different you know mutations different
gene sequences and those are what we
call alleles so the same genes but just
different versions of them
and in a severe bottleneck i mean let's
think about a population where maybe um
you know 80 percent of the population
had a certain allele and 20 of the
population had another allele for the
same gene
uh and then 99 of the population is just
gone because of one of these reasons the
one percent remaining may no longer
contain both of those alleles they may
only contain one of those alleles so an
entire allele could just be gone from
the genetic pool of the population
also in severe bottlenecks you know
think about a situation where
you've got
um
i mean just for for an example over here
northern elephant seals in the 1890s
because of over hunting their numbers
had fallen to about 30. you know it's
estimated that there were about
30
northern elephant seals left in the
1890s now those populations have
recovered a good deal since then but
only because that over hunting was
addressed
another big example is the new zealand
black the new zealand black robins right
here
recently it was found that their
population was down to five individuals
and that all five of those individuals
were offspring of the same female
okay so that right there is evidence of
inbreeding and when you have these
really severe bottlenecks where you have
population sizes falling to 30 or
falling to five known individuals on the
entire planet the rate of inbreeding
definitely increases so what does that
mean that means that when
two
siblings that have been born in the same
uh you know in the same
clutch or the same nest or the the same
from the same mother and father
that they are mating with each other or
that you have a
a mother
animal mating with her son or a father
animal meeting with his daughter
and what this does again is it weakens
the population it's much less robust
there's less genetic variation because
close relatives are already so
genetically similar and that makes these
populations less able to adapt
and so we see that there are
kind of two major possibilities that
come from a population bottleneck
so here we have a population and you can
see there's always some fluctuation
right
you know from year to year or from
season to season
various populations of animals plants
fungi whatever whatever population
you're talking about there's going to be
some variation but then you have a
bottleneck event and remember this is a
very sharp reduction remember sharp
reduction in population size over a very
short period of time so this really
steep decline
and then let's say that whatever was
causing
that
uh
population decline that bottleneck to
happen is mitigated maybe the over
hunting stops maybe there's habitat that
is set aside to be protected um you know
maybe the drought or the famine is over
but but you've got this really sharp
reduction in population size and we see
basically two different things that can
happen
you can have the population
eventually start to recover
so i'm going to write that in here
recovery
or
the other possibility
is that you have the population
continued to decline
because of its lack of robustness
because of its inability to adapt
because entire alleles have been lost
because inbreeding is happening and it's
weakening the population and eventually
that can cause
extinction
and i'll just add that even when
recovery happens
um sometimes that is
only due to
significant human efforts
to correct you know whatever it was that
went wrong
check out my other video on the
evolution of red pandas where i talk
about population bottlenecks in a real
world example red pandas have gone
through quite a few bottlenecks that we
know of and so i discuss more of that in
my video
and if you're interested also in
learning about some other evolutionary
biology topics like speciation i have
some videos in those areas as well like
aloe patrick versus st patrick
speciation so you can check that one out
too if you're interested thank you for
watching biology professor remember to
subscribe and i will see you next time
with more biology study videos thanks
guys